our secret
why don't we why don't we get started
my name is Marty Baron I'm the executive
editor of The Washington Post and we're
really delighted that all of you came
out came out this evening to the post
we're happy to to welcome you here
tonight you're going to get a chance to
meet some of the journalists and the
editors behind the posts book Trump
revealed as you know this was an
exhaustively researched book about the
life and the career of Donald Trump you
know the post has a long tradition of
delving deeply into the presidential
nominees of each major party and this
year given Donald Trump's shall we say
novel and oversized presence in the
political arena there was an opportunity
to do a book and we were happy to seize
that opportunity and we're especially
grateful to Scribner so we're here all
these folks who just came in just on
time for for making that possible I'm
not going to mention all of them but I
do want to mention that we have
publisher nan Graham raise your hand man
there we go and we have editor-in-chief
Colin Harrison here thank you for all
you did they worked incredibly fast and
incredibly hard and with impressive
skill throughout and we're very grateful
from the post there were two dozen
journalists who worked on this book they
needed to both work quickly and to go
very very deep and that's why we
deployed such a large team Scott Wilson
our national editor who unfortunately
could not be here this evening assembled
that team drawing from throughout our
newsroom from every department in our
newsroom and it all all of us came
together and in a matter of months this
evening you'll hear from five of the
people who worked on this book and you
know with the co-authors were michael
kranish who is here and mark fisher
right behind me and I'll try to step
away they were the primary authors of
Trump revealed but everyone this entire
team contributed to it and this
represents a comprehensive
emanation of Donald Trump's life his
personality his business dealings and
his long-running encounters with
politicians and politics we believe this
the kind of in-depth reporting that
readers expect from the post and with
that it's a special pleasure for me to
introduce tonight's moderator and one of
the co-authors of the book Trump
revealed senior editor Mark Fisher Thank
You Marty and thank you all for coming
out it's great to see such a big crowd
but I think I understand why so many of
you are here there's one thing that
Americans just can't seem to find enough
of these days it's information about
Donald Trump well but actually that's
kind of true because he is the first
major party candidate in 60 years since
the white eisenhower who has not
previously held elective office and what
that means is that he has not been
vetted in the way that most politicians
are as a matter of course as they run
for various offices so obviously he's
had celebrity for decades and celebrity
is actually a very different kind of
attention from having your life and
career and background rigorously
examined in the way that would help
voters understand how you think how you
make decisions and what you really
believe in as Michael and I have been
making the rounds on TV and radio
appearances in promotion of this book
we've found that the single most
effective way to sell this book was one
single Trump tweet from a guy named
Donald J Trump late of Jamaica estates
New York he the night before the book
was actually released so he couldn't
possibly have seen it he put out a Trump
they tweet saying he calling the book a
hit job and saying that it was boring
and shouldn't buy it
and of course our numbers went soaring
after that so we're tremendously
grateful to him since he informed 11
million of his closest friends about the
book but what was fascinating about that
was that that he obviously couldn't help
himself
any rational campaign adviser would have
told him just ignore the thing but he
couldn't help himself and so he did this
and it was awesome so this was
confirmation of a major theme in the
book which is that this is a man who
deeply believes that the proper response
the only proper response to anything
that could be at all critical is to
attack and to attack hard and we trace
in the book the derivation of that
characteristic of Donald Trump which
traces not only to his childhood and
having a father who taught him to be a
killer and warned him against being a
nothing but also to his relationship
with Roy Cohn the infamous New York
attorney who was kind of his mentor in
his 20s when he was just starting out on
his own in business it Marty mentioned
the origins of this book they want to
give you a little more on that before we
get going with the discussion this book
came together in late March so if you
recall back to the primary season it was
really only around that time that it
became very clear that Donald Trump was
the likely nominee and so at that point
this team of more than 20 reporters was
put together and the deal that we struck
with Scribner came to was finally signed
on a Thursday and the plan was to
announces to the public the following
Monday so the next day Friday I called
Hope Hicks who was Donald Trump's press
secretary as a courtesy to let her know
that this would be announced on the
following Monday and also to ask her we
wanted to have a series of interviews
with Donald Trump we wanted to get as
much of his time as we could because
although we had this large team of
reporters who would be digging into
every aspect of Trump's life looking at
records and documents talking to
everyone from his friends and classmates
and neighbors as he grew up all the
through his business associates partners
competitors then there's contractors and
so on and we wanted as much time as we
could get with him and so like so I
explained the deal that we'd made and
the book that we'd be doing and how a
lot of reporters would be calling them
and before I could get the full
explanation out home picks cut me off
and she said you are profiteering off
mr. Trump
which was kind of curious given that he
spent a good chunk of his day talking to
reporters nearly all of them from
profit-making institutions or ideally
profit-making situations and she was not
open to that line of reasoning and she
cut off the conversation said we will
not be cooperating with this book you're
on your own and so we have thought well
that was a fairly likely outcome anyway
that didn't really affect our plan for
how to report out this book but then lo
and behold the following Monday she
called back and said that she had had a
chance to as she put it tell mr. Trump
about your fabulous idea and and she
said that he actually liked the idea and
that he wanted us to come up to Trump
Tower as often as we like for as long as
we like because he wanted to this book
to be fair and accurate and he wanted to
get the real story out about his life so
one interest in curiosity there was that
his own press secretary who'd worked
with him for a number of months didn't
realize that he would very much like the
opportunity to talk about his favorite
subject himself but it indeed as we
talked to Trump in the weeks that
followed he regularly extended our
interview time doubled and tripled the
amount of time that he spent with us he
took all questions some of them he
answered more in more detail than others
but he indeed had us back time and again
he spoke with a number of the reporters
who are in the front row here tonight on
the phone and in person
as they went into greater depth on
topics that they were digging into we
had people working on this book who were
experts in reporting on Atlantic City on
finances on casino gaming on organized
crime connections we had people who
looked into his his brief experience as
a sports franchise owner in the US
Football League and and so on all
through every chapter of his life and
one of our goals here therefore was was
that kind of completeness and another
was transparency we know
and we document in the book that Donald
Trump is a highly highly litigious
person in fact he has sued the author of
the previous biography for five billion
dollars and we asked him Michael and I
had a certain curiosity about that when
we were talking with Trump and so we
asked him about that case and he said
that he actually never read the book so
I'm kind of puzzled by that so how do
you go about suing somebody for five
billion dollars when you've actually
never read the book and he said well you
could probably say this along with me
people told me it was a bad book a
classic trumpism and he didn't see
anything untoward about that and so he
was alternately with us very gracious
very generous with his time very open to
answering questions and yet every once
in a while he would slip in a threat
about how if it was a bad book as he put
it he would come after us and he would
come after the post so there was this
kind of alternating graciousness and
tension through the whole relationship
that we had with him and and this kind
of binary approach where you know it's
either a good book or a bad book this is
something that's also shot through the
book shot through his life one of the
things that makes him decide whether a
book or an article is good or bad is
whether it questions the extent of his
wealth and this is this is a several
anecdotes in the book about his
sensitivity to that question when he
sued Timothy O'Bryan the author of the
other biography Trump lost twice in that
lawsuit and what triggered the lawsuit
was indeed a chapter questioning whether
Donald Trump is as wealthy as he claims
to be and if you've been watching the
campaign closely you know that his
number that he gives for his wealth
varies a lot he sometimes says 9 billion
10 billion 12 million dollars and we
don't have any way of giving you a
definitive number of what he's really
worth because he hasn't released his tax
returns
but we do have ways of coming to the
conclusion that he's probably not worth
nearly as much as he says he is in fact
a judge in that libel case came to
exactly that conclusion in almost those
exact words and in fact in a deposition
in that case which we have as part of
the archive that backs up in this book
Trump was asked directly how do you come
up with this number that you bandy about
about how much you're worth and he said
quote it depends on how I feel on a
given day now there's actually something
legitimate about that because his brand
is his name and his name is what gives
value to many of his properties and
other businesses and so people decide to
stay at a Trump hotel or go to a Trump
golf course in part because of that name
so there's a clear value to it and
putting a number to that value is more
in art than a science but how he
assesses himself is he assess the actual
assessed value of properties anyone can
look up in the tax rolls and he adds the
value that he connects from his name his
reputation and his brand so he is a
tricky figure to write about in that
sense in fact when he was Comedy Central
the cable channel was going to do a
roast of Donald Trump some years back
and the directions went out to the
comedian's who were going to be roasting
him that unlike most of these roasts his
family is fair game
you could joke about his kids you can
joke about his background any of that is
totally fair only one thing in comedians
were told they may not joke about and
that was the extent of his wealth
so he's a tricky character to write
about but we did have this great team of
folks who even here from tonight and
when I turn over to michael kranish my
co-writer who will give you a couple of
examples of the things that made Donald
Trump what he is today thank you Mark
they can ready for coming out here it's
a great honor to be part of this project
I don't know if post folks know this but
I was a kid growing up in DC I was a
Washington Post paperboy for about five
years so oh the ink is not quite worn
off and I'm thrilled to be here and
working on this project I want to tell
you a story that explains I think why
biography is so important in writing
about a presidential candidate we do
fantastic stories and biography is sort
of the threads of all those stories that
we try to put together because in the
case of Donald Trump you have a man who
has never run for public office or held
public office so there's an awful lot
that we don't know about him even though
he's one of the most covered figures of
our generation so if you look at a
person's life how they've dealt with
crises that to me is one of the most
important things someone who has dealt
with dark moments in their life and
certainly Donald Trump fits that
category very very well so I want to
take you to the morning of October 10th
of 1989 in Atlantic City it's a bright
sunny day and three of Donald Trump's
top casino executives he's got two
casinos at this moment and he's about to
open a third the Taj Mahal and these
three casino executives are about to
take a helicopter ride to New York City
to meet with Donald Trump and to promote
a boxing match to be held at one of his
casinos and so the three men get on
board a Sikorsky helicopter and take the
flight to New York they have a press
conference at the Plaza Hotel in New
York they meet with Donald Trump at
Trump Tower on the 26th floor and the
meeting goes a little bit long and they
can no longer take the skorsky back to
Atlantic City so they booked another
flight a charter flight and they take it
Italian made a gusto helicopter and they
so they go to the heliport New York City
they aboard the helicopter and a few
minutes into the
right there over the Garden State
Parkway and what they couldn't have
known was that there was a small scratch
on one of the rotor blades at a 2200
feet that helicopter basically burst
apart and the three men and the two crew
were both killed and it is one of the
most tragic days in Donald Trump's life
and certainly for the people who were
killed in that tragedy and for Donald
Trump I asked him about this we had a
separate interview where I talked to him
extensively about this incident and he
does say aside from the deaths of his
parents and his brother Fred jr. that
this was most difficult day of his life
because these men were in charge of
making sure that he would be successful
Donald Trump had built some buildings of
course in New York City Trump Tower and
he was taking a big gamble in Atlantic
City at that time this was the only
legal casino operation in the East Coast
and Donald Trump wanted to be the
biggest and best operator so he had two
casinos was about to open the third and
suddenly the people who were in charge
of that had perished Donald Trump had
not really focused himself on that
business in fact at the time he was
having an affair with Marla maples and
as he said it interviews for this book
that he had taken his eye off the ball
and then suddenly he had to look at what
was going on and he realized that he was
in deep deep trouble so there was one
person he got a phone call from shortly
after the accident that name I've been
saying was John O Donnell and O Donnell
was supposed to have been on the
helicopter ride but instead he was in
Hawaii competing an athletic event and
he sent a junior executive O'Donnell now
basically had all this operation on his
shoulders and Donald Trump's met with
him but he came back from Hawaii and he
said now it's your turn and that he said
don't leave me and O'Donnell later said
that this is the first time he'd seen
such fear uncertainty and Donald Trump's
eyes and his voice and long story short
because I want to give everybody a
chance to talk and questions and so
forth what happened next was that things
had gone so bad Donald Trump had gone so
deeply in debt that there were great
great problems despite the public
acclaim for the opening of the Taj Mahal
and pretty soon all three casinos went
into bankruptcy and there were three
other corporate bankruptcies and a lot
of people were fired Donald Trump in a
fashion that we were familiar with now
said someone who was running the casino
had a Type C personality and he blamed
others but
as I mentioned he also told us he'd
taken his eye off the ball so if we tell
the story in great detail in the book
about how he managed to survive the
nadir of his career in Atlantic City and
the fact that he did survive tells you
something he basically had to look out
for himself and as he told us he said I
was looking out for Donald Trump I
needed to survive and that's what
mattered at the moment and he did
survive so with that story and
understand how he reached some depths
and also why those who have
underestimated would do so at their
peril thank you very much so when it
turns to some of the other reporters who
worked on the book Bob O'Hara was a
reporter in the post investigations unit
and he did some of the very difficult
document work on this book as well as
finding some people who are willing to
talk about that period that Michael was
just talking about in Atlantic City some
very rough times for Donald Trump and
Bob you learned a lot about Trump's
business style and about the kinds of
characters he was willing to associate
himself with in order to get a start in
a very rough and tumble of Atlantic
city's casino world tuxedos a little bit
about that it's actually remarkable
because it was a long time ago but it
feels very fresh and I think predictive
in some ways about the type of
personality that he is probably the most
formidable character that he connected
himself with was Roy Cohn and if people
don't remember Roy Cohn it's he's worth
looking into he he was the brains behind
the McCarthy hearings in the 50s and he
was a brilliant something of a prodigy
as a young man and was a pretty much a
savage legal mind who focused on
attacking as much as possible and never
apologizing and he ran into Trump in
early 70s and Trump embraced him and
they became they developed an
interesting relationship that was both
legal and friendship and Cohn sort of
squired him around New York introduced
him to a lot of powerful people and I
think that that was prob
we set the tone for much of the rest of
this career
cone represented in through the 80s and
there are qualities that we see and
Donald Trump now some of the harsher
qualities that are remarkably similar to
Roy Coons methods methods and demeanor
and just briefly tell us a little bit
about assembling the documents that gave
us insights into Trump's finances in
that period well there's a there's a
massive trove of information and we
probably tapped while we capped a lot of
it but there's a lot of material to be
examined one of the things that we found
is that Donald Trump has surrounded
himself in complexity and kind of a
cloud of obscurity throughout his career
deals or complex answers are complex and
vague oftentimes and the documents that
we were able to compile particularly
from the casino Control Commission in
New Jersey helped us to cut through the
fog of obfuscation and to get to
particulars and the one that was most
striking to me and it was so striking I
actually did not believe it for a while
until I reported it thoroughly and
realized it was true was that when
Donald Trump was trying to get his third
casino vataj he had to show that he was
financially capable of managing himself
and then making it thrive and he
promised the regulator's that he was not
going to use junk bonds to finance the
qaj and in the his testimony which is in
black and white you can actually read it
online he says that people that use junk
bonds are losers in effect and that
they're stupid and that companies that
use junk bonds are in effect chunk and
it was only and they approved his move
to go forward and it was only a few
months later that he could not raise the
money at the low prime rates that he had
promised and used junk bonds and in
making that decision and actually
signing off on those junk bonds he
sealed his fate and
his whole empire was almost certain to
go down the tubes as was predicted by a
financial analyst who was watching
everything very closely so that's the
kind of detail that we were able to mine
to get to the particulars rather than
the generalities that had surrounded him
and that he surrounded himself with Mary
Jordan is the National reporter of the
post who led the group of reporters who
looked into Donald Trump's family his
relationships with his wives three wives
at his five children and as part of that
we made an effort to talk to all of
those people talk a little bit about
what that was like and what came out of
it so I got the women and Karen Heller
is here another great reporter and boy
was that interesting okay there has
never been a president who has three
wives alive walking around that's never
happened right and where are they we
know everything this guy is on the air
all the time where is his first wife
Ivana the famous one who is the one in
fact she's from the former
Czechoslovakia who coined the term the
Donald the Donald used to refer to him
she's also the one when they had a
wicked wicked public divorce was a cover
every day of tabloids said don't get mad
get everything okay
this woman likes to talk and she just
disappeared never seen her second wife
she's still alive she's been married
four times the Donald went to her fourth
wedding but Marla maples comes along and
he's still married inconveniently to the
first woman and so this was hidden for a
while but then there was this big scene
in in Aspen at Christmastime and the two
women were fighting over Donald he loved
it it was in the paper at that time he
wasn't running for office and he loved
loved that women he was on page six with
tabloids in New York in fact many many
people we talked to said he cultivated
this he loves being in the newspaper
about this this woman and now Along Came
and that woman and Along Came Marla
maples with a great name former beauty
pageant
winner in Georgia it wasn't even like
Miss Georgia it was like miss peach but
but she was very obviously very
good-looking and younger and in the end
he got divorced from yvonna married
marla where is she she's gone you don't
see her at all during this campaign she
is around it it is really stunning
especially and the last thing I just
posted a story that couple hours ago
today about his current life or I should
say his Third Way because if you say
current life sometimes people think it's
there's more coming but but anyway so
his is for third wife Mel Melania Trump
she was Miss she has not been heard of
since the Republican National Convention
on the 21st of July we're in the
homestretch of a presidential campaign
where is if he wins she is the first
lady of the United States she has an
office in the White House he has a
public platform and she is literally
gone silent it's very very unusual as
many things in this campaign are unusual
okay so three wives all of them are not
talking while the kids are but just if I
could for a minute let's go a bit roll
back the book on his life about what it
used to be about Donald and women he
used to go on Howard Stern for instance
use the shock jock and he's gone all the
time
and Stern would say Donald what do you
think about Diane Sawyer would you do
her you know and all this kind of talk
and they would go bit and was much more
graphic than that and he was always
talking about women he was always
talking about how Princess Diana got
away from him
you know if he only had a chance really
to go you know but women defined him and
I think when we talked to people who
know him who knew him in 80's and 90's
they said you know what there are a lot
of rich people in New York there are a
lot of rich people who had buildings in
New York but there was only one Donald
Trump who was always in the paper with
some other
who wanted him that was a direct quote
from someone who knew him so I think for
a long time women got attention for
Donald Trump and for some reason I think
he liked attention and and I think that
that he when you go to his office I've
interviewed his office and I've been
talked to Melania on the phone it's very
striking that there's only really
good-looking women in the office he
talks about when his appearances not
stop
I mean he's 70 years old and I know a
lot of older people often you know when
they see somebody they they say it but
it's very unusual to have a presidential
candidate and he's getting tripped up on
this every every so often because
appearances do matter so in contrast to
the old days where he just loved talking
about Donald Trump and women we don't
hear from them anymore Mary had a
specially revealing interview with
Donald Trump's lawyer about this
question of how Trump had spent years
and years cultivating this playboy image
and inviting reporters to come out and
see him at a club when he would be there
with the prettiest models and and and
and yet his lawyer told you that when
the cameras were turned off it was
actually a very different kind of
dynamic well he would go to all the
nightclub openings in studio 54 in the
day you know especially during this gap
when he wasn't married there was a time
after Marla maples and before Melania
announced that he wasn't married and he
lists the scene but he was very careful
about how he spent his time because it
was where there were cameras and he was
always with models he would call
modeling agencies up and in fact when he
had parties make sure that his own
parties had a ratio of 5 to 1 gorgeous
women to men and he was constantly
surrounding himself with with women and
at opening so I said to his lawyer Jake
Kolbert I said you know how did he have
time for this he's always telling me
that he's work as you know when he
worked how could I do all this stuff
Mary I mean I'm working I have all this
money and responsibility I break
buildings have you seen my great
buildings you know
how could I possibly have been with all
these women at so is Jay Gould rude this
and he agreed completely he said
actually you know he just likes he's on
the Trump Tower and he works in part of
it he really just likes to take the
elevator up and turn on the tube and
watch TV and so I said this to Trump and
then Trump said well you know maybe it
wasn't as glamorous as it's all out to
be so I mean image you know he was great
at getting attention I mean how many
women did he really have and how much TV
did he have he I don't know
Robert Samuels is a national political
reporter at the post and Robert looked
into the transition that Donald Trump
made from celebrity to politician and
the roots of his interest in running for
office and so tell us a little bit did
he see this as a completely different
kind of pursuit or it was a kind of a
natural progression for him right well
one of the governing questions that I
was really interested in finding was why
is this man doing this and it was very
clear from speaking with people who knew
him that at some point he didn't realize
the phenomena and the movement that
we've seen sweep across the country what
we know through his pulse through his
political life and affiliation is that
he didn't really have much stomach for
partisan principles between 1999 and
2012 he changed political parties seven
times he's donated between 1995 and 2012
he donated 3.1 million dollars by
himself without looking at his companies
to all sorts of politicians he donated
to Clinton he donated to Carter he loved
Ronald Reagan so what is this about
really and to do that we started looking
at lots and lots of footage and
interviews that he's done over the years
and we talked some people into showing
us the unaired unedited versions of this
of these tapes and early on from his
very first major network television
interview in 1980 we see a theme that
starts to emerge he's talking about a
building and then he begins to rail on
the idea that America is being laughed
at that there's something that's
happening in the political system where
leaders aren't strong enough like they
used to be and he begins to ponder
whether or not politicians today can be
like in Abraham Lincoln and he says
Abraham Lincoln could never win in 1980
because he was too ugly he did not look
good on TV and he didn't know how to
master the media and the President of
the United States in this modern era
needs to know how to do these skills and
so what we see over the course of time
is Donald Trump assessing politicians
and presidents on their ability to
affect messages to affect messages to
communicate messages effectively and to
figure out whether or not they make the
country feel great again and everyone
does a pretty okay job until Obama who
he considers a total disaster
by this point in 2012 Donald Trump has
mastered the celebrity that he said
those great minds in 1980 did not master
he's become the star of The Apprentice
he has his Twitter following that
everyone enjoys because he's talking
about everything from whether or not
Barack Obama's from the United States to
whether or not Katy Perry's marriages
are going to work out and he decides
that he is in fact the person who could
best symbolize the greatness and tough
leadership of America and so there's a
lot of there's been a lot of skepticism
about whether or not Donald Trump wanted
to do this whether he wanted to run for
president but it is true that days after
Romney lost that election he was the one
who filed an application to the Patent
Office and he copyrighted one phrase and
that phrase was make America great again
and so you see the thematics of his
campaign starting from early on in his
public persona but it's been it had been
something had been thinking about and
toying around with for several decades
great what there's one piece of video
that you got from it was an old Rona
Barrett celebrity interview from 1980s
which had never aired or we've got parts
of it that had never aired and he was
remarkably similar in the way he talked
about political issues but he was also
very frank about he could be sort of
dynamic about what was making him decide
to run and not to run it was that it's
interesting and maybe it's because it
was so early in Donald Trump's political
career but Rona Barrett really got
probably the best information out of
Donald Trump's and any interview that I
had seen us notwithstanding and if you
see you see him going through he said he
says Donna Rona Barrett asked well do
you want to be President goes no it's
it's to me know of a life I love
building I'm an artist I love building
my buildings and over time it really
affects him and he starts to take to
this idea that huh maybe one day I could
be President particularly because people
continuously ask him whether or not he
wants to be the president of the United
States and he shows up in polls through
through the decades again and again not
because he was running for anything we
could but because of his name
recognition people put him on polls and
and he did very well so it kind of built
but we want to turn it over to all of
you to take your questions so if you
will raise your hand one of the folks
who the microphones will come by and
start you grab go ahead yep
you discuss his personality was he
warned did he look you in the eye was he
reserved did you see him with melania a
little bit about his personality
sure in our interviews at Trump Tower
they were in his office on the 26th
floor with this glorious view of Central
Park and Fifth Avenue and he was very
courteous and it was because I said
before quite generous with his time
we never saw Melania we did see his kids
would wander in Ivanka and Eric would
wander in from time to time and talk
with him about business trip they were
going on or problem at the property in
Miami but he's very soft-spoken in that
setting you get none of the bluster that
you familiar with from the rallies and
he on the other hand it is difficult to
have a linear conversation with him you
can ask him about stuff and he he knows
his field extraordinarily well if you
ask him about business deals he made in
1978 he will remember building materials
and subcontractors names and the whole
process of making working through a
negotiation but if you ask him anything
that veers off of what he knows best the
knowledge base is very thin and he tends
to change the topic very quickly a
sentence or two and he's off on to
something else it has his sort of base
topics that he goes back to when he's a
little bit flustered about not knowing
something and so he'll just all of a
sudden start talking about his TV
ratings here is another thing that he
would do is I spoke to him only on the
phone several times if he was pressed on
something he would almost seem to get
caught in a groove and he would repeat
the same thing over and over and over
again and sometimes one of my colleagues
Drew was especially adept at this he
would sort of say mr. Trump mr. Trump
and kind of bring him back he's on
course and then we'd move on but it sort
of joking aside it was it was really a
pronounced thing to be talking with
someone who seemed to veer off again
caught in a groove he's a completely
different person I think in in person
he's really charming is very nice he
knows your name and he looks at you I
mean everyone says that it's not this
bombastic guy that you see on TV and
everybody that's worked with him over
the years say I turn on the TV I work
with this guy for 20 years turn on the
TV I know who this is
gentleman here yep Walton
Huntress of the aspects of trumps life
and experiences that you researched what
of the challenges or situations were
most analogous to the actor that kind of
challenges a president faces and and
what can we learn from those
I mean you've you've your book has
researched I'm looking forward to the
chance to read it how he dealt with
women how he dealt with celebrity we
don't with you know and and in business
deals but this is clearly not a direct
analogy to what a president would face
and so what can we learn what what is
most instructive in this in
understanding what he would what he
would be actually like as a president
Michael well you know it's a great
question and the the parallel is what he
did running his businesses and nearly
all the businesses that I ran were
private businesses so they're difficult
to examine until you go through
ancillary sources like sino control
commission records which Bob and other
reporters did for example he did at six
corporate bankruptcies he has often said
he had four corporate bankruptcies this
is instructed to understand how he sort
of thinks and clearly there were six and
we asked him to explain what he when you
say four what do you mean and he said
well I think of the three casinos as one
bankruptcy in fact there were three
separate court actions for pre-packaged
bankruptcies as they call them there
clearly were three separate ones but him
it's one and part of it he wants to put
the best image out there but the answer
directly to your question is that he was
told by his father
don't go deeply into debt and as Bobble
Harrell mentioned he end up going into
junk bonds he was
of millions or even billions of dollars
in debt time and again he thought that
he was not going to survive we talked to
a person who was basically given the job
of negotiating with bondholders and
banks and that person told us that he
was very concerned this is someone who
knew Donald Trump as well as anybody and
he was very concerned about Donald Trump
at this moment he said I'm looking at
him bankruptcy after bankruptcy he's in
a midst of a huge divorce he's building
humiliated day after day in the front
pages of newspapers and I worried that
you know he might take his own life
it's a very striking statement for
someone who actually feels
affectionately about Donald Trump and
what he said was but when I walked into
the office of Donald Trump there he was
his suit was perfect his tie was perfect
as well and he would say you know what's
next what do we do next and he had this
ability for whatever reason to instead
of looking at oh my gosh there's all
these terrible problems to try to be
thinking positively one of his mentor's
was no more Vincent Peale of the power
of positive thinking that could even
mean that he's attached from reality if
you look it that way or that he just is
so positive oriented they just want to
think about some of the deep problems he
had but the reality is is that while he
certainly says he's a great business
person that his businesses had trouble
time and time again drew Harlow could
talk more he's here in the audience that
reporter who worked on this but he had a
public company at one point one time
only because they had to raise a lot of
capital and that company did do well at
first it paid Donald Trump millions of
dollars the stock ticker of djt for his
initials but the stock price went from
something like $35 to 17 cents and the
shareholders were very angry there were
lawsuits filed that we write about but
the bottom line is is that Trump was
able to survive another example of being
at the absolute depths and finding a way
for himself to survive and this is
instructive this is you know Donald
Trump views it as you know I am there
it's his words are a one-man army and he
talked in one of his books about the
power of narcissism for example he cited
a book by that name and he said it's a
very powerful thing if you want to be
successful
you have to think in that sort of tunnel
vision way you know only about making
sure that you do survive and another one
of his points of the book think like a
billionaire he advises that you have a
quote short attention span unquote so
either he sees that as an attribute or
he knows he has this particular
disposition and he tries to put it in
the most positive way but examining that
business career and seeing you know as
we try to do in the book you know the
peaks and the valleys and exactly how
he's operated it seems to be the best
guide for how he might try to operate as
one huge question comes up there is that
he is the first president who has a lot
of foreign Holdings as people look at
his foreign policy
you know he's expanding abroad Kevin
Sullivan orthere went to Azerbaijan we
had reporters in Moscow looking at his
dealings there in Panama and we've never
had anybody who would be in the White
House who has their global business
empire and so your good question is is
how would this work if you're going to
divide divestment is it enough to divest
himself is the Trump Organization with
the kids I mean the value goes up of his
holdings all around the world and he is
increasing his worldwide holding it goes
up if he's in the White House I you know
if you think about what do presidents do
they synthesize information and come to
decisions they persuade people of their
positions and they they have a program
of some kind well Donald Trump is not
someone who takes in information very
deeply he we asked him about how he
makes decisions whether what he reads
and he says he doesn't read reports or
briefings or anything like that
he doesn't like to read anything of any
length he will keep he believes that he
make comes to decisions by gut by
instinct and so he very much wants
people to come in and tell him about
something orally and he believes that he
will get the nub of it in a matter of
seconds he's obviously very good at
persuading people that that he knows a
way forward but when it comes to
persuading people individually in the
way that the president has two to one
coalition's and and achieve compromises
that's something that he's done
very little of in his career he talks
about being a great negotiator and we've
certainly spoken to some of his business
associates who credit him for that but
we've also spent a lot of people who
worked with him who say that it is all
about getting his way and he's not one
to to reach compromises this over here
good Mike that note right here wonder oh
he's strong anti Mexican narrative in
this campaign which has pretty much
defined the campaign
where does it come from and did you have
people in Mexico researching or looking
into his deals there could it come from
his frustration apparently he didn't go
very well down there well I was the
bureau chief in Mexico for five years
with my husband Kevin Sullivan and we
went to interview the last two
presidents to talk about this Vicente
Fox in Philly spelled their own and as
far as we can tell and especially having
been at rallies it comes from a lot of
people in America like what he has to
say and he knows that he gets reinforced
every day it may be the most popular
thing he says there's no hint that he's
always mean not like Mexico or anything
he his gift is that he is saying this is
what we keep hearing at rallies and
talking to millions of Americans they're
fed up and he says and he'll tell you
that interviews too is that he's a
reflection of what people want you know
he thinks that our immigration policies
have been wrong wanted to amplify that I
think one thing that's safe that with
Donald Trump although we can't be sure
of it is that he's actually the
embodiment of a populist politician and
we've had a history of those going back
200 plus years and they emerge
periodically and the patterns are very
similar they say what people want to
hear they try to they try to appeal to
people to anger and frustration
and it's possible the Donald Trump
doesn't have any animus towards Mexicans
and that he's only playing the cards
that he sees are out there for him to
play with and if that's the case we
should be troubled because what we need
to some degree in our leaders I suppose
is is a general sense that they're
telling us what they really feel in the
truth and at least pursuing policies
that are sort of generally in the
interest of the country to add to what
Bob saying I'd like to contrast this
what his current position on Mexicans
with what he said in the previous time
when he was really close to running for
president in 1999 and 2000 at the South
point he was considering running as a
third party candidate against Pat
Buchanan's remember him and Donald Trump
said that the reason he'd be a better
Reform Party candidate than Pat Buchanan
was he was all about inclusiveness and
he did not like the way Pat Buchanan
spoke about numbers of people including
Jews blacks gays and Mexicans what we're
seeing now when you go to the rallies
and you experience that and he said it
himself is that when the crowd gets low
he loves to bring out the issue of who's
going to build the wall because the
crowd goes nuts it's a way to add
something to the political perspective
that people can understand and that they
have a very visceral response about and
for him that's very important in fact
we've spoke to a number of people who
are talking to him about the decision to
run for president and when he talked
about the issues that were really
important to him the relationship with
Mexico didn't really come up in fact a
number of them were surprised when he
talked he made the allusions to rapists
and criminals crossing the border in the
first speech one of the people who we
spoke to was most who's closest to Trump
gave us some guidance and said when
you're trying to understand his motives
always go first to the idea that he
thinks of himself foremost as a showman
and he will always choose the most
provocative line of attack because he
wants to get
in response the affirmation from the
crowd yes sir over here I want to ask
about something that's really important
in a president and that's his temper I
want to let you know that in the 80s in
early 90s I was in charge of promoting
Atlantic City so I'm a little bit of
knowledge about this when Donald Trump
saw an article in the Atlantic City
press or worse an editorial he pulled
the newspaper off the newsstands in all
of his hotels and Atlantic City magazine
which they also owned he didn't like
what the casino Association did he
stopped paying the dues which was 25
percent of the budget so I always think
of him as petulant I was ordering if you
found in your research anything that
would give you some guidance as to what
his temper will be like if he gets
elected he he said that he's you know
said it many times that I can be a
screamer quote unquote and I'm familiar
with the anecdote you're talking about
in Atlantic City and the person I
referenced when I started talking this
evening was John O'Donnell who wrote a
book called trumped exclamation point
and in that book he repeatedly cites
these temper issues and temperament
issues and in fact O'Donnell got so
frustrated with this temperament that he
ended up quitting the scent of a note
saying I'm leaving
I asked Trump about this he said no Jack
O'Donnell didn't quit I fired him so
he's go back and forth over this but you
do hear that from a number of people and
Trump himself has said that he has a
screamer those are his own words as to
how that would reflect you know Bob
mentioned Roy Cohn Roy Cohn was the
lawyer for Donald Trump when the US
government sued Donald Trump on his
father Fred Trump for race bias in 1973
and Roy Cohn advised Donald Trump when
you're hit hit back ten times harder or
a hundred times harder and that you know
is the root of his personality to a
great degree he absorbed that lesson
actually settled that case eventually
but time and time again we see cases
words you have a lot of lawsuits and he
is you know he has imbued that
philosophy hid himself in that case also
gave him an animus towards the federal
government
he settled the case only after dragging
it out and attacking righteously the
prosecutors through roy cohn and that's
an aspect that he's more than a screamer
he is very open about wanting to punish
people who he often uses his phrase
viciously attack me and you know a lot
of politicians one payback can come an
hour later but so he fits into that mold
and it's worth noting that a lot of
Americans find this appealing again I
think that there's a lot of people who
think this guy when he's hit says he can
hit ten times harder and that's what
he's going to do out there they like his
you know confidence and he is clearly
feeding off of enormous amount of
Americans were like what they see on TV
and that pugnacious attitude is
something that we trace in the book all
the way back to his childhood and with
number of examples and stories going
back to elementary school of really kind
of ruffian behavior as he calls it yes
sir
guys really amazing people
thank you all for sure on your side okay
my question my question is which is very
scary for me is that after 2000 the
press said they fell down on the job in
not going after Bush's motives for going
into Iraq and it wasn't until a day or
two ago I have seen the press begin to
say this isn't true and not merely
report on what he is saying but some
juxtaposition of it he said this this
day said that they they and actually
confronted because you know I'm very
scared about voters who as you said let
their passions they like what they hear
but my credo is let's get the fact that
argue about conclusions what do you
expect the press to do what is the
obligation of the press to hold him
accountable
I'm not definitely told that the
Washington Post but in general to hold
him accountable and say you can't or you
can't make these allegations when the
facts Brian all right we've actually I'd
say everywhere we go we got a question
about this sense that many people have
that there's been light or non
aggressive coverage of Donald Trump we
also get the same question about Hillary
Clinton and you know I think the
reporting that went into this book also
said more than 30 major stories that
appears in the post over the last few
months that go into great detail in in
pushing back against Trump's own
narrative own version of his life and
successes and career but you're right
there are other aspects of a news media
that have not been as aggressive in
doing the reporting that we think is our
obligation in any presidential campaign
in any campaign so you know I think
particularly in television there are
real questions to be asked about giving
over vast stretches of time to running
his rallies and so on you know greatly
more time than was given to other
candidates but you know we can't control
what they do we we decided that this was
our obligation to do this deep reporting
and commit enormous resources to this
book and the stories that have appeared
in the paper will continue to appear in
the post I mean the post has been banned
by Trump for and you know I mean he
hates what we write we have-we have a
fact checker full time we've had all
these big stories but you know it is a
key question I think the debates and
strong moderating in the upcoming
debates is absolutely critical because
that's when everyone's watching because
people look at one story and then they
call up they'll see one story about
Hillary Clinton and they'll say why
aren't you going after Donald Trump and
then they'll see one thing about Donald
Trump and why this so the the debates
are a rare time they're both there and
it's going to depend a lot on the
moderators and on the rock or vote just
to be clear he made the idea that you
know hasn't been talked about the last
couple of days this has been written
about for months by other organizations
by organization many times the fact
checker that Mary mentioned I mean they
do extraordinary work where they check
everything in almost real-time and
there's a story up today that basically
they went over again what Donald Trump
said he did not he said that I was
against the war from the beginning but
in fact every fact check has shown that
that's not the case that he said on
Howard Stern but he was not he didn't
say he was against the war at that time
so every time that statement is made the
facts I could put things out to say no
that's that's not actually correct so
all the way in the back
[Music]
what he says or is it all just part of
the show
it depends what he's saying uh I mean
it's hard to believe sometimes when
talking to him that he actually means
what he says I think it's also important
to note that you know there's an
accuracy question and there's an honesty
question for people and for many people
who support Donald Trump it's not so
much the facts but it's the genuine
passion that he elicits when he's
speaking and I think that's a very
important distinction to make and it's
an important distinction to acknowledge
the fact that he gets up there and he
says something that aligns with people
it's an empowering feeling for those who
feel that the Obama years have
disenfranchised their ideas of how the
country should operate and what a
political leader should be and one of
the things that has been so important
for its candidacy is that skill is one
skill that Hillary Clinton has
acknowledged that she really struggles
with and so I think you know when we
talk about this genuine question I think
a lot of voters are wondering whether or
not the person in the candidates are
genuinely listening to them and on that
front Donald Trump is yes press with how
many of our institutions are being
privatized and I see this as potentially
giving other people who have aspirations
to enter into a power structure the
chance are we are we looking to a day
when we're going to profit from many of
trumps pawn in our political system
I don't know where to start I think you
know I'm I'm out there I'm talking to
voters a lot and I think in some senses
yes I I mean I think people have been
drawn I mean it seems so far ago but you
know six months ago everyone was talking
about Bernie Sanders and the impact that
he was having on the Democratic the
Democratic Party in that process and I
were seeing a lot of different types of
voices entering to the standard
two-party system and that will
inevitably change who people pick and
how they perform in terms of when
they're trying to in vote yes sir
I've been pondering is building on this
other question and a lot of people seem
to say well the checks and balances he's
not really going to do we think you're
going to do what reason we really think
with the forces that he's unleashed and
the legitimacy by the attention given to
some of the racism and bigotry and
things like that that forces have been
unleashed in our society that the checks
and balances we think exist maybe won't
exist and I get really troubled for
instance when you see former members of
senior officers on both sides get
involved and it just I wonder what kind
at what point do we become close to a
banana republic you know at what point
do are we being to say well he's really
doesn't mean it does it really matter if
he doesn't really mean it if he's really
about power and the forces that he's
unleashed become bigger than him and you
have like the SA out there or you have
I've heard this so many times that you
know it's really just a presidency I
mean and they're not kidding they say
look at Washington I mean as Congress
really not much gets done it's the image
he's a strong guy and number two he's
not the same old thing so that's what
they're electing and for some amazing
reason so then we started writing a
story about actually the president has a
lot of power
I mean it seems so obvious but you're
like you can get us into a lot of
trouble very quickly and we should keep
writing that because that sentiment is
out there and even more than that that
you'll talk to people in your site
well you support the Muslim ban but you
how would that work exactly and then you
start talking about the money and how it
work and they go well you know we don't
think he's really going to do that
because it's just more like that he's
going to be strong against it and he'll
be thinking about how what he wants to
keep that people and the same with the
wall you're like wait a minute it's
2,000 miles how much how much money
would that cost
and again so he's getting this benefit
of because people want him to say it
they shouted the rallies and yet they're
like oh we don't really expect it's
going to build it it's the sentiment it
said he wants to it's that we're he's
telling us
I hear you you're fed up with all the
immigration and a lot of people who
think that NAFTA was bad took their jobs
so he's just better than his opponent
kind of connecting with people through
TV there's a there's another aspect to
your question and it comes from the word
Unleashed I've had this in the back of
my mind for a long time before the
election but it's really coming to a
play in the last several months which is
I think what we're seeing now has been
in play has been developing and
unfolding and unpacking itself for about
15 or 20 years maybe twenty five years
and the separation the lack of comedy in
Congress the ironically with the rise of
the Internet we've seen a surge a deep
deepening of anti intellectual behavior
and I sort of feel like it's come into
play almost cresting now at this
election and to me that's the more
trouble those are the undercurrents that
are more troubling because it's not who
gets elected president necessarily it's
deeper trends in our society which I
suspect we'll be exploring after the
election because they're not going to go
away immediately but I would just have
one cautionary note because
there's an assumption often about Trump
opponents that the rallies are these
gatherings of extremists and racists and
so on and it's just not the case there
are there are crazies at his rallies to
be sure they're extremists but there are
also a lot of I did a story a few weeks
ago about Obama Trump voters and there
are a lot of them and these are people
these are the Hope and Change voters and
these are people who saw in Barack Obama
someone who heard exactly the kinds of
things that Robert and Bob mentioned and
and took that to heart and reflected
what the frustrations and troubles that
people were going through and a lot of
those same people see that in Donald
Trump and those are not extremists so a
time for just one last question yes
ma'am thanks to that term skills
Asia vetoes required you know if you
credit everything yeah I mean that's
what you would mean you he would say
that I mean and people respond to his
confidence and he said he has said that
he will get really smart people around
him and I mean it's all about the
confidence and he is not I mean he has
not said you know what is Aleppo yet but
but we did learn that he would have
caught Osama bin Laden before 9/11 today
but seriously I think I think the
undercut of your questions are really
important thing to explore and
throughout this country I think there's
a big debate over what is the
requirement for a president right and
for Donald Trump he said what the
requirement was 30 years ago and he
reiterated it 20 years ago and that was
a person who could Rhian reinvigorate
the spirit of America who has boldness
and pomposity those are his words and so
does he fit think he fits the
requirement
absolutely I think I mean the question
is a sort of values question on what the
presidential seat be and that's you know
that's where things get interest what's
remarkable at Trump is that he's always
had this very small circle of people he
can really rely on they're usually a
couple of family members with the
casinos there were one or two people
like I mentioned who died in a
helicopter crash and time and time again
you see that there's one or two vital
person the persons who can really tell
them what to do he does prefer having an
acolyte he doesn't like to be told that
he's wrong and so oftentimes you see
people being fired you seen again in
this campaign he's gone through two
campaign managers already so that would
be a big question for him as president
he would have to tackle many many issues
that he doesn't know anything about and
we rely on that advice how would he
organize that and synthesize that so I
think that's one of the big questions he
talks about getting things done the best
way is an army of one and it's very hard
to run a country with just one person
and I would say that this is going to be
a key thing in the debate because
Hillary Clinton has made it's a polar
opposite she's had all this experience
in government and he is certainly going
to answer this and say that he has a
temperament he's shown through his
businesses and he has the confidence to
get the right people around him if he's
right he'll completely redefine what it
means to be president given his
biography his track record his lack of
experience in the public life if he's
right he'll be the first person to come
this far an election he is the first
person to come this far in an election
campaign and if he's elected that will
he'll break all the molds and he has a
ready answer for your question which is
when things go right he he was fully
prepared he knew what to do and he takes
all the credit and when things go wrong
and we show this at various stages
throughout his career when things go
wrong the system is rigged we've heard
these words from him in recent weeks and
that is that is exactly the phrase that
he uses throughout his life when he's
faced with troubles or failure so when
we hear that now you can sort of see the
gears moving and he is
he's not oblivious to his position in
the polls and so he's preparing himself
and all of us for the message that he
will have if he loses so I think we have
to leave it there but thanks so much for
coming out and supporting the book
[Applause]